BRET?
>> Bret: WE'LL CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW THIS STORY.
CASEY STEGALL IN DALLAS, THANKS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS THE U.S. IS
STANDING WITH THE PEOPLE OF CUBA
TONIGHT FOLLOW.
SO LARGEST ANTIGOVERNMENT
DEMONSTRATIONS IN DECADES.
CORRESPONDENT PHIL KEATING HAS
REACTION TONIGHT FROM LITTLE HA
VANNA, FLORIDA.
>> AN UNHEARD OF UNPRECEDENTED
DEMONSTRATION AGAINST THE CUBAN
COMMUNIST REGIME IN A DOZEN
CITIES ON THE CARIBBEAN ISLAND.
BOLD DEFIANCE ON THE
GOVERNMENT'S TOUGH GRIP ON AND
EXHAUSTED WITH DECADES OF
POVERTY AND FOOD AND MEDICINE
SHORTAGES.
EVEN ACCUSING LEADERSHIP OF A
FAILED RESPONSE TO CORONAVIRUS
FOR WHICH THE STATE DEPARTMENT
WAS CRITICIZED AFTER INITIALLY
TWEETING THAT WAS THE REASON NOT
INEPT COMMUNIST RULE.
IN MIAMI'S LITTLE HAVANA FILLED
ONE HUNDREDS, IF NOT THOUSANDS
OF SUPPORTERS IN SOLIDARITY WITH
THE CUBAN PEOPLE.
ALSO CALLING FOR CHANGE AS THEY
HAVE FOR THE PAST 50 YEARS WITH
NO SUCCESS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN THIS AFTERNOON.
>> THE UNITED STATES STANDS
FIRMLY WITH THE PEOPLE OF CUBA
AS THEY ASSERT THEIR UNIVERSAL
RIGHTS AND WE CALL ON THE
GOVERNMENT OF CUBA TO REFRAIN
FROM VIOLENCE, THEIR ATTEMPTS TO
SILENCE THE VOICE OF THE PEOPLE
OF CUBA.
>> CUBANS ON SUNDAY ALSO
MODIFIED THE REVOLUTIONARY
PHRASE FREEDOM OR DEATH.
CHANTING FREEDOM OR LIFE.
FLORIDA'S CUBAN AMERICAN SENATOR
MARCO RUBIO POSTED THIS ON
TWITTER.
>> OF COURSE VOFD HAS A ROLE TO
PLAY.
THIS BEGAN WELL BEFORE COVID.
THESE PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED.
THEY WANT TO LIVE IN A NORMAL
COUNTRY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE THEIR
KIDS GETTING ON RAFT AND HAVING
TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY IN ORDER TO
LEAD NORMAL LIVES.
>> THE CUBAN PRESIDENT CANAL AS
USUAL BLAMED THE ISLAND'S
PROBLEMS ON THE U.S. AND ITS
TRADE EMBARGO.
IN A NATIONAL ADDRESS HE ACCUSED
THE U.S. OF MANIPULATING
EMOTIONS AND FEELINGS THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA.
U.S. SECRETARY OF STATE BLINKEN
SAID IT WOULD BE A GRIEVOUS
MISTAKE FOR THE CUBAN REGIME TO
BLAME WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE AS
A RESULT OF ANYTHING THE U.S.
HAS DONE.
>> THE HOUR OF FREEDOM HAS
ARRIVED.
>> MIAMI'S CUBAN AMERICAN MAYOR
JOINED THE CHORUS FOR CHANGE.
>> PEOPLE ARE DYING.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING BEATEN AND
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING AND THEY'RE
STARVING.
AND THIS HAS BEEN HAPPENING FOR
FAR TOO LONG.
>> NOTABLY MOST LEFT LEANING
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN QUIET ON THE
CUBA ISSUE TODAY, INCLUDING NEW
YORK REPRESENTATIVE ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS, HOWEVER,
DID MAKE A SHORT STATEMENT HE
PROTESTS EVERYWHERE AND HE
STANDS BY HIS INTERVIEW HE GAVE
LAST YEAR ON "60 MINUTES" WHERE
HE SAID NOT EVERYTHING IN CUBA
IS BAD ON THE STREETS OF HAVANA
TODAY QUIET NO, DEMONSTRATIONS
AND THE INTERNET AND SOCIAL
MEDIA HAVE LARGELY BEEN SHUT
DOWN.
BRET?
>> Bret: PHIL, QUICKLY, WE KNOW
THE CUBAN AMERICAN POPULATION IN
LITTLE HAVANA INTENSE IN
EVERYTHING THAT COMES OUT OF
CUBA.
DO THEY FEEL ON THE STREET THAT
THIS IS A GAME CHANGER MOMENT
THERE?
>> WELL, SOME OF THEM ARE NOW
CALLING FOR THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
TO INTERVENE IN THE ISLAND
NATION.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY JUST LIKE
BACK IN 2016 WHEN FIDEL CASTRO
DIED TO COME GATHER.
PEOPLE DRIVE BY VERY SLOWLY
HONKING HORNS ALL DAY.
AND PEOPLE BANGING POTS AND PANS
AND HOLDING SIGNS DEMANDING CUBA
CHANGE.
LIKE I SAID AFTER FIVE DECADES
OF CALLING FOR THAT, NOTHING HAS
HAPPENED I